right now in 2021 i've recorded and
uploaded over 120 videos to youtube
and generally speaking you'd think the
video with 72
000 views would be by far my top earning
video
however you would be so wrong if that's
what you're thinking
right now the best video that i've ever
published
only has 10 000 views and generates
160 dollars per 1000 views
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about my most
profitable video of
absolutely all time like i've already
mentioned
it isn't the video that had 72 000 views
it isn't any of the videos in between it
is the video with only
10 000 views now this is very strange
and very odd but we're going to break
down these analytics and look into
exactly
why this video performed so much better
than anything else i've put out on
youtube today
okay so let me slide across a little bit
and use this rear monitor as
a projection so at the moment my average
last seven days is about seven dollars
and sixty six
cents per one thousand views now
from a youtube point of view that's
actually pretty good most creators that
i've looked out there are anywhere from
three to four dollars all the way up to
about ten so i'm definitely sitting at
the higher end of the spectrum
so let's start with the video with 72
000 views
you'd think 72 000 views would have made
me a substantial amount of money
i gained about 400 subscribers over the
period of time it has been up
it was published about the same time as
the video that made me the most amount
of money
so let's look at the analytics and the
revenue
on 72 000 views keeping in mind that i
average 7.66
per 1000 views if you want to do the
math quickly this should equal about 552
australian give or take a little bit now
if i swing around and click on the
revenue you'll see
that since published i've only made
90.54 cents
and averages at 1 and 24 cents
per 1 000 views that is horrible
the 72 thousand views for this video
alone
basically meant nothing especially when
you compare it to the 10
000 views which i'm about to break down
in just two seconds
now i don't know why but this video is a
complete outlier from all of my other
videos
keeping in mind 7.66 is the average i
get
per 1000 views let's take a look into
what this top video is
so as we can see this video has had
about 10 000 views and it has generated
over a thousand dollars
you can quickly do the math that's about
a hundred dollars
per 1000 views and if we break it down
to the last seven days
it gets even scarier in the last seven
days this video alone
is generating a hundred and sixty
dollars
per 1000 views now that
is seriously significant compared to
everything else
it's a hundred and sixty times more than
my
most viewed video on youtube in 2021
now let me explain why i personally
think this video
wix vs squarespace versus shopify has
done
so so well in comparison to every other
video i've ever put out
we're no longer going to need this
screen so i'll tap that off
and slide back in the center like i
already mentioned the top video
in views was the surface laptop review
whilst
the top video for revenue was wix versus
squarespace versus shopify
both of these have two completely
different target audiences
and as somebody who's been in the
marketing game who's been in advertising
and obviously in e-commerce
i can understand why the wix video has
done
so so much better so fundamentally
speaking youtube
targets people who are willing to click
on their ads and willing to spend money
an e-commerce video is generated to
basically encourage other people to
spend money
to create their own products or to buy
other products
so already that target audience is ready
to spend the money and ready to invest
whilst a laptop review well people will
look at those in the millions and
millions of views
look at mkbhd for example who is one of
the biggest and best tech
youtubers out there right now in 2021
and he gets millions of views on every
single video
however i could almost guarantee that
somebody in the e-commerce or the
marketing space
let's take graeme stefan for example
because he has
actually showcased how much he earns or
potentially even andre
he did a video just a couple months ago
outlining how much he made on youtube in
2020.
andrei jig for example made 1.6 million
i believe it is off top my head
usd in 2020 and he only has
1 million subscribers whereas mkbhd
has about 10 million or so and i can
probably almost guarantee
it was a lot less than this two million
dollar mark
now why it's because the target audience
is already
ready to spend the money it's because
they're looking to invest so the youtube
algorithm is pumping those ads
and they're charging a lot more for
those ads they know if you spend five
dollars you're probably gonna make fifty
dollars
it's that niche target market of people
who are already ready to spend
now i know that's a bit of a tongue
twister but for those that are ready to
spend
you're definitely gonna get a lot more
views and a lot more money
on the video that is targeted at the
people
already doing that now you might be
thinking to yourself
why david haven't you continued down
this road obviously this one video did
really well
you could have made a fortune this is
very much so true
but there's only so much content you can
actually generate
on ecommerce before just repeating the
same thing over and over and over again
i didn't want to be that guy on youtube
that comes back with a different
thumbnail
but exactly the same content i wanted to
be able to actually produce
good content regardless of the financial
reward anyway that's all for me today
guys thank you so much for watching i
hope you enjoyed the video
i hope you got some good information out
of it that you can take to your channel
and help you create better content if
you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below
and because it's february and we're
doing 28 videos in 28 days
i will see you tomorrow